[soft music]
>>Male Presenter: Ever since Descartes, thinkers
have been fascinated with the mind-body dichotomy.
With the emergence of computers in the middle
of the last century, computer scientists began
to play with what Fred Brooks called "pure
thought stuff," thus putting our hands directly
on this dichotomy.
Like many other immensely powerful, or even
magical, substances, this thought stuff is
dangerous. The digital pioneers, some of whom
are here, who innocently opened Pandora's
Box did not realize that in so doing, they
would start a process that would not only
change the fabric of society, but might even
begin to change the way the next generation--
the digital natives--actually think. When
I was a child, everyone worried about the
threat that nuclear weapons presented to human
society as a whole.
Maybe, in fact, the real threat is our computers.
Who knows? Thirty years ago, Sherry Turkle,
a sociologist and psychologist, realized that
something important was happening and came
to MIT to begin studying this phenomenon at
one of its epicenters. Unlike the geeks, she
did not study the computers themselves.
But rather, she studied the computer users.
First the digital pioneers and subsequently,
the first generation of digital natives. During
this epic journey of exploration and discovery,
she has written numerous books, three of which
are particularly important reports on her
observations of the new digital world.
"The Second Self: Computers and the Human
Spirit," in 1984, "Life on the Screen: Identity
in the Age of the Internet" in 1995 and today's
topic, her newest book published last week,
"Alone Together: Why We Expect More from Technology
and Less from Each Other." I give you Sherry
Turkle.
>>Sherry Turkle: Thank you.
[applause]
It's a pleasure to be here and I'll be talking
mostly, of course, about "Alone Together."
But let me just say a word about this trilogy,
because really this is the third in a, in
a set. The first book, "The Second Self,"
was about the one-on-one of the psychology
of why the person-machine psychology is so
compelling.
And I wrote about how people really achieve
an almost Vulcan mind-meld with a computer
when they work intensively with it. The psychology
to program, the psychology of really feeling
at one with your machine and the way the machine
comes to externalize a piece of yourself.
The line in the book that captured that for
me was the 13-year old girl who said, "When
you program a computer, you put a little piece
of your mind into the computer's mind and
you come to see yourself differently." And
that's what gave me the title, "The Second
Self." And the second book, "Life on the Screen:
Identity in the Age of the Internet," was
really about how we started to step through
the screen.
And through avatars, the early virtual worlds,
MOOs, MUDs, the early AOL experiences, we
really began to learn about what kind of lives
we could live on the screen. What kinds of
identity play, what kinds of experiences was--.
Being other than ourselves, experimenting
with self, we could have in this new playful
space.
And I was very positive about that. I felt
it was a very exciting, new thing. And I want
to get back to that in a minute when I make
a comment about reactions to "Alone Together."
And then this new book is really about something
that I didn't see, that I began to see really
right after I finished working on "Life on
the Screen."
My model, what I was studying in "Life on
the Screen," when I studied all these people
on Moos and MUDs and starting to be with AOL,
were basically people sitting at desks with
windows open on their screens, cycling through
the windows on their stable, sitting computers
and even laptops. Right, I would say, I finished
that book in 1990--.
It came out in 1995, which means I finished
it in 1995, 1994 and a half. And then I would
say in 1995 and a half, '96, I met Steve Mann,
who was basically wired up as a cyborg and
showed me, along with the other people who
at that time at the media lab called themselves
'cyborgs', what it meant to be always on,
with your technology always on and always
on you.
I mean, it was a glimpse into a future that
we're all living now. I mean, because basically,
everybody here who has any kind of mobile
technology is living the world that those
early cyborgs were pointing to. And it was
that--. In those days, the cyborgs, many people
took those cyborgs to be handicapped.
I mean, they looked, they were wearing backpacks,
an antenna. They were not elegant creatures
and they were dealing more with people feeling
sorry for them and wondering if they needed
special equipment and how to live looking
like that. But I hadn't seen, I hadn't realized
in all of that discussion of identity play
and all that stuff, what it would mean, and
this is my, this is my, my lack of seeing.
I hadn't thought through, in "Life on the
Screen" what it would mean if it were always
on, always on you. And basically, for the
past 15 years, I've been following that story.
As that story has developed, I've been following
it for grown-ups who came to get used to it.
And I've been growing it for the cohort of
children who then became teenagers and so
forth, for different generations as they matured
as we've gotten used to living in that kind
of culture.
And as we've gotten used to living in that
kind of culture, [sniffs] I've developed some
real concerns, as I said, mostly from the
point of view of a psychologist who studies
developmental issues. And I just wanna say
in the beginning, I'll tell you a little bit
about those concerns. Obviously, they're in
the book.
They're the concerns of a psychologist and
an, and an anthropologist as I study these
generations and I've studied contemporary
behavior. I take nothing back. I was on the
cover of Wired Magazine. [laughs] I love all
my gadgets. I love computing. I love technology.
I take nothing back from all the things I
said about the identity possibilities of the
computer, about the wonderful things it brings
us.
But that doesn't mean that as I've seen this
new development of always on, always on you
computing and what it means to always have
the possibility of also being elsewhere, that
I haven't seen some things that I think we
need to rethink and take seriously. And I've
been very interested in the--. I'm thrilled
to speak at Google and to have time to [sniffs]
interact with you because I've noticed in
the reviews of this book, and one that's coming
out in the New York--.
Particularly one that you haven't seen yet
because I just saw the advanced review. It's
coming out in the Times on Sunday. It basically
is, "She was on the cover of Wired Magazine.
She loved this stuff. Now, she doesn't." It's
like technology and I were dating and I--.
Like a spurned lover. And I think there's
something about it.
And there was one in the Boston Globe, similarly.
"She used to love technology. Now, she doesn't.
What's the matter?" And I think there's something
about that reaction to that it's all about
me and whether I like technology. It's all
about why don't I like technology anymore.
That is so far away from what I intended in
writing this, what I intended when you read
it, what I'm trying to be about.
It's not all about me. It's not all about
my technology lover. It's not all about whether
you feel spurned. It's not all about whether
you love or hate technology. Technology is
our partner in making our lives, in constructing
the self and how our kids grow up. It's not
like we're stuck with it. It is, it is, it
is our--. We are in a human dynamic partnership
with technology.
That is how it is and how it should be and
how it always will be. The question is--and
here I differ from Kevin Kelly--it's not what
technology wants. It's what kind of partnership
we make with technology to get it right to
serve our human purposes. So, I say this--.
I don't mean to sound defensive. I don't say
this really in a spirit of defensiveness,
but in a spirit of as you are at the epicenter,
here, of really making, setting the terms
in some ways of this new kind of partnership.
Be aware, be very aware, that there's a tendency
to play this game as though you're for or
against technology. A tendency in the media,
a tendency in people who are cultural critics
of technology who are out there. And I'm just
saying that I think that that's a dangerous
frame of mind because this is not about being
for or against it, this is about getting the
human journey right.
So, for example, when Mark Zuckerberg says,
"Privacy is,"--what did he say? He said yesterday,
"Privacy is no longer a norm." And I tweeted,
"What is intimacy without privacy? What is
democracy without privacy?" Now, that wasn't
to take an anti-Facebook stance. And right
away, I get back, "That's an anti-Facebook
position."
I don't think asking "What is democracy without
privacy?" is an anti-Facebook position. I
wasn't turning down Facebook on a date when
I raised that question. It wasn't an anti-technology
position. It was simply saying, and certainly
to you at Google, "What about democracy without
privacy? What about intimacy without--?"
Let's talk about this. I mean, these are not
questions that necessarily take positions
against technology. These were questions that
people need to ask in an open, free society.
And they should be talked about. And I'll
get to more of these in greater detail in
my formal remarks. But, to ask a question
like that, "What is intimacy without privacy?
What is democracy without privacy?" and being
attacked as having an anti-Facebook position.
I just think it's a curious--. It isn't my
intent, but I want those questions discussed.
I want them discussed for kids. I want them
discussed for the society at large. I just
think these are, these are questions that
shouldn't have to do with whether you like,
or don't like, technology. So let me tell
you a little bit about how I got to this book.
I mean, first of all, I told you about the
cyborgs that got, that got me thinking about
the "always on" culture. But they really were
two, there are two threads in this book. Two
things, basically, started happening that
complete--. 'Cause after they started happening,
after I finished "Life on the Screen," where
I thought I would take a little bit of a break.
And even though I'd been working on this book
15 years, it really reports on 15 years of
research because two things started happening
that I felt that I couldn't write about until
I saw them develop over the long span of time,
because I thought they were very complicated
things. And I really wanted to see almost
a generation try to deal with them.
And of course, you never know when to stop
and I almost arbitrarily chose a 15-year time
frame as saying, "Look, it's a 15-year. Look
at how these two things have developed." And
the first were sociable robots which, from
a certain point of view, may seem to you to
have nothing at all to do with social networking,
but in my mind actually, the two stories interweave
and I hope you'll find when you read the book,
if you read the book, that they interweave
in interesting ways.
So, sociable robots, what interests me about
them is that it turns out, because I'm obviously
interested in questions of substitution for
the face-to-face, the one-on-one, the being
with each other in a body-to-body, eye-to-eye
contact. The sociable robots are robots and
I’m not against robots--love the robots--not
against robots that do stuff for you: vacuum,
clean, dishes, the robots in war that, that
go after the bombs and go into the dangerous
places.
Very pro-robot woman, just on the record.
[audience chuckles]
But the robots that really started to get
me interested and upset again from a psychological,
developmental perspective, are the robots
that make eye contact, gesture in your direction,
say your name, and crucially, track your motion.
Because when a robot does that, and in the
book I tell the story of my first meeting
with Cog, which is a robot that does that,
when a robot does that it turns out that you
are toast 'cause you feel that somebody is
home.
Because we are biologically programmed. We
are human animals. We are programmed that
when something does that to us, we feel as
though we're with another one of our kind.
Because there simply was nothing in our biological
past that knew how to do that. And so, when
we meet one of those, we feel that we're home
with another creature like us.
And when I met Cog, again, just as I was finishing
"Life on the Screen," I think I met Cog in
1995, I met, I met him in Rodney Brooks' laboratory.
There was another person who came into the
laboratory with me and I knew exactly how
Cog worked. I had all the information in the
world about how this robot worked and I started
competing for his attention.
Excuse me, its attention. And there again,
it's almost impossible not to think of it--
that was not an information processing error.
That was a Freudian slip. I absolutely could
not help myself, but to want to have this
robot's attention. And part of me is saying,
"Get a grip. Get a grip." And part of me,
it's not about information about how the robot
worked. It is absolutely visceral.
It's the quality of the experience. And so,
I began to do studies with kids and not kids,
with these sociable robots that are designed
not to be intelligent. They're not smart.
They're smart about pushing your Darwinian
buttons. So it's not about their intelligence.
It's about our vulnerability. And I wrote
this book.
The metaphor in "Alone Together," is about
human vulnerability and the technological
affordances, that these are technologies that
are built around what is human vulnerability
and what are the technological affordances
that push on those human vulnerabilities.
And that's the story of the socialable robots,
in which people are actually willing and wanting
to substitute robots that seem to care for
people in more circumstances than I ever would
have dreamed possible.
Women who want to have a robot boyfriend.
And I mean seriously, women who want to have
a robot boyfriend because they basically say,
"Look, I'm just looking for a feeling of civility
and comfort and somebody being home, somebody
being there." Really not caring if the robot
understands in any deeper way.
People wanting to have a robot companion.
People -- and it's as though a feeling of--.
It's not about feeling that the robot understands.
It's a feeling about our having given up on
each other in some kind of, in some kind of
way that was a way to track. And so, it's
a complicated story about why people, again,
understanding the limitations of robots, are
willing to settle for that, much as they're
willing to settle, I think, for giving up
the human voice in, in, in,in other kinds
of communication.
So the robot story and then the story of "I'd
rather text than talk." In the robot stories,
I want to say one thing that surprised me.
I began to study the earliest sociable objects
'cause I wanted to get really--I believe that
everything starts in the nurseries. One thing
for me to meet Cog as a grown woman, but I
wasn't socialized to love these objects.
And the first objects that were there to study
where the Tamagotchies and the Furbies. And
the Tamagotchi is an incredibly important
actor. How many here ever remember Tamagotchi,
so I--. OK, so you know. The Tamagotchi asked
for love. It asked for nurturance. And it
turns out that nurturance is the killer app
in sociable robotics in the following sense.
That we don't just nurture what we love. Human
beings are programmed to love what we nurture.
So that any – a digital creature that asks
for nurturance gets us to love it. So, nurturance
is the killer app in forging a connection
with a digital object. And if you look at
people's relationships with digital objects,
the most successful ones--the Tamagotchi,
the Furby--are the ones that ask you for something.
And I traced that story and the history of
the sociable robotic revolution. Nurturance
is the killer app for sociable robotics. And
that story, for me, goes along with the story
from the other direction, which are the temptations
of the new relationships that we can have
with each other via mobile connectivity, always
on and always on us.
We now expect the control over time and emotional
resources that texting and messaging provide.
We don't use the voice minutes on our phones.
We'd rather text than talk to the point that
talking comes to seem intrusive, a demand
on our real time. This is the results of my
interviews, hundreds and hundreds of interviews.
We turn instead, obviously to Facebook, to
friending, to Twitter, to worlds in which
we play avatars, being ourselves but not quite
ourselves. One of the very interesting things
I found in studying both gaming and social
networking is there's a very surprising paradox
is that when we play an other, for example,
an avatar in World of Warcraft, we end up
playing aspects of ourselves.
In other words, you think you're playing really
a very far out avatar, but you realize that
you're playing an aspect of yourself, something
that I'd already seen and studied in the MUDing
world. But when you go to places such as Facebook,
where you think you'll simply be yourself,
you end up playing a role.
You end up in a life of performance and self-presentation,
which has very important, very important decisive
implications for adolescents because you can
say, "Oh, look. All the time, you're always
performing. Everybody's always performing.
Everybody's always performing." But when you're
really with people, face to face, in the real,
there are ways in which you have moments,
you have glimpses, you have ways of feeling
like you're not performing, of having those
moments when performance slips away and you
relax.
You're yourself. And there's something about,
in adolescence, a constant culture in remembering
this culture of performance that starts to
be a problem in Facebook. Particularly, for
adolescents. So in these lives of performance,
I've found again, my work is qualitative.
It's interviews. It's a lot of interviews.
It's interviews over long periods of time,
but it is interview work. I'm trained as a
clinician.
That's my value added. That's what I know
how to do. We face confusions. The first working
title of the book was, "Cyber Intimacy/ Cyber
Solitudes" because I really found that the
main finding was that people didn't know when
they were together and they didn't know when
they were alone.
And the original "Alone Together" sums that
up in a more popular language, but the original
title was "Cyber Intimacy/ Cyber Solitude."
In our lives of performance, we face confusions.
At the end of an evening of avatar to avatar
chat in a network game, people feel, at one
moment, in possession of a full social life
and in the next moment, they feel curiously
isolated in a tenuous complicity with strangers.
We recreate ourselves with new bodies and
jobs and homes and romances. You build a following
on Facebook. And then you wonder to which
degree your followers are your friends. You're
together with other people and yet, one second
later, you feel utterly alone. So, in one
of the stronger statements of the book, I
say you're tempted to substitute objects for
people, or possibly to treat people as though
they were objects.
Chat roulette is my favorite example of literally
treating people as though they're objects.
You're an object. I don't like that object.
Next. I like that object. Next. So there's
a parallel in solitude when you're with a
robot. You are alone. Trust me. You are in
solitude when you're with a robot.
You feel a new intimacy and when you're in
intimacy, you're with another person. When
you're with another person online, you have
potential for intimacy. And people still,
because of the medium, can feel a new and
unexpected solitude. And those are the two
parts of the book that I try--decided to make
it one book--to try make those two things
play off each other.
So here's a psychological implication of this
new connectivity. Today's teenagers tell me
that when they have a feeling, they turn to
their online, online contacts on Facebook
or on their phones, because sharing the feeling
has become part of having the feeling. So
when you live in a world of continual connection,
people who are only a touch away are there
for continual validation. It's "I share, therefore
I am."
We move from, "I have a feeling. I want to
make a call," to, "I want to have a feeling.
I need to make a call." "I have a feeling.
I want to make a call" to "I want to have
a feeling. I need to make a call", which is
a very different thing. Or, "I want to have
a feeling". More likely, "I need to send a
text". When we use other people in this way,
you can get used to seeing them as spare parts,
as ways to support our too fragile selves.
So again, to summarize the thesis of the book
and why I put these robots and the connectivity
together in a way that might seem not obvious.
Alone with robots we feel connected. Together
with people but not fully relating to them,
we feel alone. So I say we're at the still
center of a perfect storm. And I think of
this, I sum this up as the robotic moment,
not because we all have robots.
We don't all have robots. But I like to think
of it as the robotic moment because it's a
technological moment, in which we fear that
our lives with technology have gotten out
of control and we fantasize paradoxically,
and it's a fantasy. It is not like a happening.
We fantasize that it is technology that will
help us reestablish control.
So we feel our lives have gotten out of control.
Hundred and fifty emails. I mean, how many
emails do you guys get a day? Seriously. Are
you ashamed to say, to speak it aloud, the
number that dare not speak its name?
>>Female Audience Member #1: I get 400.
>>Sherry Turkle: You get 400? Do I hear five?
[laughter]
Anybody willing to admit to 500?
>>Male Audience Member #2: Work emails, or
personally?
>>Sherry Turkle: OK, let's just start, messages
of any sort. How much do you have--. How many
messages of all sorts do you need to respond
to every day? [pause] Because the point here,
I'm willing to admit to a thousand. I'm willing
to admit that I need to respond, between the
email, the texts, the crucial Twitters that
say, "You're a jerk."
[laughter]
The Twitters that have to be answered because
they, they, or I, feel that they have personally
insulted me. I'm willing to admit text messages,
urgent, please, letters of recommendation
that need to be, 'cause now anybody can reach
me at any time.
So a letter of recommendation that needs to
be done tomorrow no longer seems an outrageous
request. It can be a thousand. It can be 1200.
Just constant, constant, constant, constant.
And I'm -- the argument in this book is that
when you--and it's not an argument, this is
actually the findings from my interviews--that
doctors, lawyers, Indian chiefs, management
consultants, professionals of all stripes,
are willing to say to me that when you get
that much input and you have to respond immediately,
you start to ask questions that you know can
be answered quickly.
You start to give answers that you can answer
quickly. You start to dumb down the questions
and dumb down the answers. You start to get
into a vicious circle of asking the questions
that can be answered quickly. We start to
degrade. It's not--. We're degrading our culture
in terms of business problems in two ways.
First of all, we're asking each other questions
that we can get quick answers to, because
you're simply, the volume and the velocity
picks up to the point that you just know that
you're dumbing things down because you know
somebody wants an answer right away. And so,
you're gonna get that conversation at a lower
level so you can get back right away.
And then we're dumbing it down in the sense
that we're not talking to the people in the
next office. People--now maybe here you have
this magnificent space. I've, I've read about
your culture and I hear that here, here you
make a big effort to avoid this. But the people
I've interviewed talk about emailing people
in the next cubicle because they don't want
to intrude on them.
So we have to fight. Again, I mean, from what
I read, everything here is trying to tell
you, "Please don't do that. Please talk to
each other." But out there, that's a norm
to not want to intrude on the person in the
next cubicle. And actually, I begin the book
– maybe I forget. I begin the book with
a story of a mother. I mean, it's not just
in the business world.
But of a mother who’s trying to hire a nanny.
And she goes to the nanny's house because
she wants to see the nanny in her own home
environment. And the nanny's roommate opens
the door and the mother says, "Well, I am
here to see this woman." And the girl starts
to text her. She's texting a woman who literally
is 10 feet away.
And she says, "Well, why don't you knock on
her door?" And she says, "Well, that would
be intrusive." So the notion that any kind
of face-to-face becomes intrusive. And when
I interview the people who don't want to intrude
on their colleagues by knocking on their door,
by sharing the coffee, by, you know.
And I say, "Well did you ever?" And they say,
"Oh, yeah." And they start to talk about it
as though those were the Golden Years, the
good-ol' times. And I say, "Well, why was
what was so collegial then, so intrusive now?"
And you can see them thinking and they end
up with something like, "Well, they have so
much more to do now."
And read that as they have so much more email.
They have so much more email to take care
of now. And that's not so different from being
at Thanksgiving dinner, or being at a dinner
party, or being at a conference and watching
everybody around you answer their texts and
their phone calls, rather than pay attention
to you.
I mean, there's something that's become more
compelling to us, or the mores has become
more compelling to us to answer that virtual,
that person who's not there than really the
people who are around us. And this is a question
of psychology. I mean, this is not the place
to go into it. Read the book.
But I mean, psychologically, I know a lot
about why the fantasy of that unknown call
is more compelling than the person who's in
front of you. Just trust me. It is for very
deep reasons. So, part of it is we're fighting
something very deep psychologically in us.
But part of it is the way in which we establish
social norms around technology.
And it has now become the social norm that
really you do, when you're having dinner,
put the phones on the table. You really do
interrupt a conversation to take a call. I
tell a story about going to a funeral and
having--of recently going to a funeral of
a colleague--and people texting during the
funeral.
Last night on the Colbert Report, one of the
people who were back hand, one of the stagehands,
was talking to me about going to a memorial
gathering for a family member. They were sitting
Shiva and people were texting during the Shiva.
And everybody has, everybody has a story.
I happened to put some of the stories in the
book, but it's not because that's what ethnographers
do. But it's not as though my stories, and
as an ethnographer I have a rule, that if
I find a story and I only find one story like
it, [cell phone rings twice in the audience]
or two stories like it, I don't tell it. This
is not about sensationalist reporting where
if I find a weird story, I put it in the book.
No. No. This is about--. I mean, I took 15
years to make sure I had a lot of stories
and a lot of backup. This book has a deep
bench. So if I tell you people are texting
at funerals, it's not because I once saw a
funeral where people were texting. We're giving
up, we're giving up on something about ourselves.
And this is about--. This is in our control.
Let me just end by saying, because I want
to make sure I have time to take your questions,
I wanna end on just two things that--. [pause]
At this robotic moment we have to be concerned
that the simplification and reduction of our
relationships is no longer something we complain
about.
Because we start down a path of substitution
with the idea that technology provides alternatives
that are better than nothing. Then we think
that perhaps technology is better than some
of the available human connections. And finally,
we play with the idea that technology might
be better than any human connection.
From better than nothing to simply better.
So let me give you one example from robotics
and then I'll just end and talk about the
final, the final – just the wrap-up point.
Some of the -- let me talk about the robotics.
So, this 11-year old girl starts off by saying
that a robot dog might be better than a real
dog because her father is allergic to dogs.
Next in the interview, she thinks the robot
dog is better than a real dog because it will
never die. [pause] Then, the child allows
herself to muse that a robot dog could be
made to stay a cute puppy, more gratifying
than any real dog could ever be because everybody
would always love a puppy and here's a puppy
that would never die.
So you start off with "allergic, it's better
than nothing." Then, "always stay a puppy,
might be better than some dogs." "Never die,
always stay a puppy." You know, "a robot dog
is better than any dog could ever be". So
in the book, I trace story after story, relationship
after relationship, not in a spirit of being
sensationalistic.
Not in the spirit of "Apocalypse Now," but
just to show the psychology of how you--.
And this is why I ended up including the robots.
These very simple robots that look like nothing.
I wanted to show how with even simple, simple
1995 objects, you can get people to talk about
a psychology of how technological substitutes
can come to seem more potentially more valuable
than the real thing.
Elder-care robots, something I feel passionate
about. There's lots of money, lots of development
of robotics for the elderly. Don't tell me
you're developing them in this--. This is
something that I think is really a problem.
I call it love labor lost. Nanny-bots, Eldercare-bots,
substituting robots for one really--.
We have a human compact to care for each other.
People telling their life stories to robots
who don't know what a life is and who won't
know what a life is. And who don't know--.
Older people trying to tell their life story
and how they lost a child and how a child
died to a robot who doesn't know what it is
to be a mother and have a child.
These are not--. These are moments that it
doesn't mean that I fell out of love with
technology. These are moments where it's important
to ask, "Why are we doing this? What is this
technology for? What are we accomplishing?
Does this serve our human values?" When you
watch this, when you watch these old people
doing this, you have to ask yourself, "What
is the point? What human value is being served?"
When you watch a child being baby--. The idea
of a babysitter robot and you think about
robots that will socialize a child. A robot
that has a limited number of facial expressions.
Or even, the robots of the future that will
have more of them. What will they know about
the infinite variety of speech and gesture
and body movement.
What, what, why would we want a robot to be
teaching our children about the fluidity of
gesture and motion and voice? This is people
work. What is the point of these substitutions?
So, this is why I bring these two issues of
sociable substitutions together. And in my
view, sociable robots and online life both
suggest the possibility of relationships the
way we want them, just as we can program a
made to measure robot.
We can reinvent ourselves as comely avatars.
We can write the Facebook profile that pleases
us. We can edit messages until they project
the self we want to be. We can edit messages
until they project the self we want to be.
And we can keep things simple. Our new media
are well-suited for accomplishing the rudimentary.
And because this is what technology serves
up, we reduce our expectations of each other.
An impatient high school senior says to me--this
is a great quote from the book--,"If you really
need to reach me, just shoot me a text." And
he sounds to me just like my colleagues on
a consulting job that I just finished, who
tell me they don't need to talk.
They'd just rather avoid face to face meetings
and would prefer to communicate with real
time texts. So, every technology asks us to
confront the questions of whether it expresses
our human values, a question that demands,
again, that we ask what these are. And this
makes technology a precious partner as we
think through our futures.
We're at a moment of significant choice. We've
agreed to a series of experiments. I think
of them as forbidden experiments on ourselves.
Robots to mind children and the elderly. Technologies
that denigrate and deny privacy. Seductive
simulations that present themselves as real
places to live. I think we deserve better.
And when we remind ourselves that it's we
who decide how to keep technology busy. When
we remind ourselves that it's not what technology
wants, it's what we want, I think we'll have
better. And I just wanna end with several
points, some general and some specific for
business. The general comment is just remember
what is the moment where you're at.
And I think I said this in the beginning.
It sums up in the phrase, "Early days, just
because you grew up the internet, just because
you grew up with the internet, don't think
the internet is grown-up. It is time to make
the corrections. It is a moment of opportunity."
Second, do not fall into the trap of allowing
yourself to use the phrase, "It's an addiction."
When people talk about "I'm addicted to this,
I'm addicted to that, I'm addicted to Facebook,
I'm addicted to Google", it gets you--. If
you're addicted to heroin, one thing to do,
get off heroin. When people talk about being
addicted to Facebook, Google, surfing, searching,
it makes them feel impotent and hopeless.
We're not going to give up this technology.
We have to learn to live with it in a healthy,
productive way. It's like food. It's more
like saying you can't control--. You're having
a problem with the cookies. Well, let's really
think together about the cookies. I mean,
you're having a problem with food? We have
to think about how we're live most healthfully
with food.
That's been a problem for a lot of people
over a long period of time. Sometimes, it
can feel like an addiction. But this technology
is here to stay. And when people use this
phrase, "the horse if out of the barn", it's
over. It's over. Privacy is over. Privacy
is not over. We need privacy. Without privacy,
really you have some choices between dictatorship,
demagogues.
Privacy's not over. We have to just learn
how to live with this technology in the kind
of privacy we need to have the kind of open
society we need. And there's like, "privacy
is over". You have to learn how to live with
this. So all "the horses out of the barn",
"we're addicted". They're just ways of deferring
and not dealing with the problem.
OK, that's are my general--. That's my really
general thing. And then, things on a business
level that I think you really need to be thinking
about, I've made reference to them, but I
really wanna mark the moment. This thing about
asking ourselves simple questions because
you want instant answers on email because
the volume and velocity of texting.
You simply need to create environments where
we can ask the more complicated questions.
Universities all over the country are just
turning off that wireless in the classroom.
And because you're asking your students a
complicated question, you cannot afford to
have them shopping while they're trying to
think of the answer.
I mean, you really do need--. Some things
just need full attention. And our problems
are so great that we just need to get back
into the habit of making some spaces for full
attention. And second, we are too connected
to think. We need time for reflection, real
reflection. We're not taking the time to think
because we're too overwhelmed by the volume
and velocity of our constant connection.
And this is a problem that we're gonna face
together in the next decade. We all need to
be partners and it's not about liking technology
or not liking technology. It's just about
forming a right kind of partnership with it.
Thank you.
[applause]
Thank you. And I'd be thrilled to take your
questions. Hoping to have questions.
>>Male Audience Member #3: Hi.
>>Sherry Turkle: Hi.
>>Male Audience Member #3: So first of all,
thank you very much for the talk. It was very
thinking enticing. And I think [clears throat]
one of the biggest things in the case for
me to take away is that we simply need to
be aware of these things and be thinking about
what we're doing.
I do have a question regarding your "this
is people's work" statement.
>>Sherry Turkle: This is--.
>>Male Audience Member #3: This is people's
work. So--.
>>Sherry Turkle: People's work.
>>Male Audience Member #3: Yeah.
>>Male Audience Member #4: Taking care of
the elderly.
>>Male Audience Member #3: Taking care of
>>Sherry Turkle: Ah, ah, ah, ah. Right, right,
right.
>>Male Audience Member #3: So, it seems to
me that dealing with technology is something
that's replacing some things that always happened,
right?
>>Sherry Turkle: Right.
>>Male Audience Member #3: Because in the
past, little kids had dolls. I have a nephew,
2 years old. He has a doll. He puts her to
sleep. He feeds her.
>>Sherry Turkle: Right.
>>Male Audience Member #3: He takes care of
it as if it's a human being. I have friends
who have pets and they talk to them. They
share everything with their pets.
>>Sherry Turkle: Right.
>>Male Audience Member #3: And these phenomenons
have always been the same, but maybe technology
made it more vast and more common and allowed
people from all levels--.
>>Sherry Turkle: So why do I think the social
robots are different?
>>Male Audience Member #3: Yeah.
>>Sherry Turkle: OK. That's a great question.
Because one of the things that I've been able
to do is study dolls and social robots in
parallel. And what's the psychology of playing
with dolls and what's the psychology of playing
with social robots. [sniffs]
When you have a doll, and when, actually when
psychotherapists use dolls in therapy, what
a doll allows you to do, the affordance, the
technological affordance of the doll, is that
it allows for projection. So if a child is
feeling guilty--let's say a girl. She puts
her Barbies in a row and she puts them in
detention. In other words, she feels guilty.
She does unto the Barbie what she imagines
should be done unto herself. If you have a
doll that's telling you how it feels, that's
making demands on you, that has its own needs,
its own agenda, it's own -- it's a sociable--.
That's what it means to have a sociable doll.
It's its own little--. It doesn't leave the
child that space.
It takes the air out of the relationship from
that point of view and it's another demanding
creature. So, it's, it's not serving-- before
we get into what other possible problems it
might be causing, it's not allowing for the
wonderful things that your niece and nephew
are doing with their stuffed animals, their
stuffed bears, their dolls, their pets.
So, on the other hand, because of the special
seductions that it has, and it's built to
be seductive, it draws the child in because
it makes the child feel recognized. And unlike
the Barbies, when it asks for nurturance,
it really asks for nurturance. And unlike
the Barbie when it asks for nurturance, it
says "thank you" back and forges this bond,
but it's a bond that goes no place.
So it forges a bond, but it's not a bond that
can then develop because really the doll has
nothing to give back. So, what do I think?
Do I think these dolls will be out there?
Do I think these dolls will have their place?
Do I think--. Of course. But I'm just saying,
"Attention. You're playing with--." I don't
want to say you're playing with fire.
You're playing with very fundamental processes
when you get into two-, three-, four-, five-year
olds and how they deal with nurturance and
bonding and dolls. In other words, you can't
have it both ways. You can't have, you can't
say you're creating a radical technology that's
dealing with the most powerful processes of
socialization and then say, "Oh, well it's
only a toy."
And that's what I, that's what I object to
in the sociable robotics discourse. It's like,
"Oh, we're dealing with the most powerful
processes of socialization. Oh, it's only
a toy." And for the older people, there there's
gonna be a lot of room for disagreement. Be
a lot of room for disagreement. I think where
the disagreement is gonna come, it's gonna
come on Alzheimer's, it's gonna become in
the area of dementia.
And there I think there's gonna be room for
a lot of disagreement in, in, in really a
spirit of good will and honest disagreement.
That when people don't know who they're talking
to, when you could argue they don't know who
they're talking to, does it matter who or--.
Is it a who or is it an it? And I think there's
already some very interesting, very responsible
conversation about that.
But when you go into a nursing home and you--.
I mean, my daughter brings dogs and people
to work with the dogs and the people together
in nursing homes in Cambridge. And she can't
get people to go in. She tries to organize
the program to bring people in to working
in this nursing home. It's time to bring some
people into this nursing home.
And the argument for bringing in the robots
is that there are no people for these jobs.
And there are a lot of people for these jobs
if they were paid and given compensation and
trained to do it. One of the things I come
down very hard on, I mean, the one place in
the book I do sound a little bit schoolmarmy
really is that argument there are no people--.
Every robotics presentation I go to at these
conferences starts with this, "There are no
people for these jobs. We need robots." And
when you look at the economics of this particular
industry, plenty of people, just not enough
compensation and benefits. But there's gonna
be room for disagreement on dementia. I mean,
but I think there should be responsible conversation
about that. But Nanny-bots, I'm gonna take
a hard line.
>>Male Audience Member #5: Thank you for coming.
My question is your thesis seems to be based
on some kind of psychological and biological
determinism that we are fixed in how we deal
with the world. We look at a robot and we
think it's a person when I know for a fact
we can be reprogrammed, right? People were
programmed to deal, to treat slaves as some
other, as the other.
The Nazi's programmed Germans to treat Jews
as the other. So it's not like some of these
are completely fixed. So the real question
is, and we had technological events that have
changed our social interaction: radio, TV,
the move to the suburbs. So the real question
is why do you think this is an apocalyptic
change and why do you think that we will not
be able to compensate for it? And what do
you think that form of compensation will be?
>>Sherry Turkle: Well, I'm arguing that, I'm
arguing that we will if we have our wits about
us. That if what guides us is our, is where
we want it to go, we will form relationships
with robots that will be in our best interest.
But I think it's, I'd put first, "where do
we want it to go?" as opposed to "we will
somehow go someplace with it".
I think that's the difference between -- Kevin
Kelly and I are very close friends and colleagues
and I think the difference between us is that
he thinks that together we will evolve into
something--what technology wants. And I think
that there is questions of human choice here
about where do we want it to go.
So I do think that we're going to evolve into
new kinds of partnership with technology.
But I think that the question of whether,
for example, you--. The book begins with David
Levy practically dedicating the book to me
because he thinks that I will, here's a good
example. In, in, in 1980, the early 1980s,
I interviewed a lot of computer hackers who
were socially, feeling socially left out at
MIT.
And this one guy, called Anthony, it's not
his real name, it's his made-up name, who
said he felt that he really couldn't get along
with girls. This was a limitation. And David
Levy wrote a book. He's a computer scientist
and AI person. He wrote a book called, "Love
and Sex with Robots," in which he talks about
marriage to a robot and he dedicated the book
to Anthony because he thought that this would
be a perfect solution for Anthony.
And he sends me a copy of the book. "To Sherry
Turkle's Anthony." I should give it to Anthony.
This is a perfect--and he writes in the book,
"This is a perfect solution for Sherry Turkle's
Anthony. We will evolve to a point where we
will happily--everybody like Anthony." In
other words, people who feel a little bit
socially inept will have a robot to marry.
We won't have to get over the problems of
being with people. We can all have robot husbands
and wives. So, that's an example of where,
in David Levy's mind, we're gonna co-evolve
so that we see robots as adequate partners.
In my mind--.
>>Male Audience Member #5: Right, but you're
assuming that it's gonna last more than a
week, right? I mean, there's this assumption
there that this is really gonna work.
>>Sherry Turkle: I'm just, I'm just saying.
I'm just saying. From your point of view,
hundred years from now, 150 years from now,
in terms of evolving and reprogramming, I'm
trying to take your thought to a--. Here's
a guy who thinks as you do, but really takes
it out there, we'll evolve, the robots will
evolve.
Kevin Kelly said everybody's gonna co-evolve
and we'll be at a point where we'll see robots
as adequate partners. And I say [pause] "Why?"
Anthony wanted to be--. He felt like a kid
at a candy store with his nose pressed up
against the window. He wanted to be let in.
He wanted to have more skills to be let into
the world where he would feel more comfortable
with people.
He didn't want to be told, "You're a little
socially inept. You get to get a robot bride."
So I say human values first, and then let's
figure out how to, how to live with this technology
in ways that--. I'm against these substitutions.
So in that sense, I would have to say in all
honesty that I'm a little bit species o'centric.
I have a species chauvinism in contrast to
these other writers about technology. [pause]
That's it. I think that's a fair owning up.
>>Male Audience Member #6: So, what you've
said makes me think about a technology transition
that happened in the 1700s. Before that, novels
didn't exist and people didn't read novels.
And people started reading novels and in particular,
the young people started reading them.
And the establishment, the older generation,
were shocked and horrified and just very disturbed
by the reading of novels. They thought that,
that the reading of novels would lead to deep
perversity, to the destruction of society
as they knew it, to the end of humanity. And
we came to peace with novels in some way.
'Cause before that, you couldn't tell a story
with an inanimate object. You couldn't evoke
emotion. You couldn’t evoke desire. You
couldn't evoke a lot of the human things that
you are talking about in your analysis here
using inanimate objects. And with novels,
suddenly that changed. And people were, in
a fundamental sense, rightly disturbed. I
don't know how we got past that, but we clearly
did because now in fact, if I found my son
reading a novel, I'd be delighted.
[laughter]
So, what I'm curious about is are there any
lessons for us in terms of your research?
From our experience as a, the race, the human
race, with the comprehension of something
like novels, fiction, the romantic novel that
came to be in that time.
>>Sherry Turkle: [pause] Well, I think we're
going to become, and I think we already have
become, appreciators of [pause] search as
a genre, as an occupation, as a way to explore
the world. The notion of search, I mean, who
searched? I mean, you had an encyclopedia.
You got to a static entry. It was boring.
It was long. It was written by people who
knew where they were.
But the notion of surfing, the notion of search,
the notion of this liquid float, I think that's
become a language. Without getting into multitasking
and if you're doing it while you're making
love, [audience laughter] without getting
into the--. Just getting into the genre thing,
that you sit down to have an experience that
was unknown [pause] 20 years ago, 15 years
ago. I mean, it just was an unknown experience.
And I think all of us remember the first time
you had a connection fast enough that you
had a--, because you needed a fast enough
connection to have a sense of what it is.
I mean, it couldn't be that you sat there
and I mean, there just came a point when you
had a new experience. And it must've been
like, for me, it was like reading--.
It’s felt like a little bit like reading
that new novel. This was just something radically
new. And I think it's been a miraculous, fabulous
thing to watch a world discover this new adventure.
Now, I think just like you learn that if you
just never--. It's like there's a wonderful
story by Woody Allen, the Kugelmass episode
where he lives inside "Madame Bovary".
Does anybody know this Woody Allen story?
Anyway, he, he, he, he goes to visit a magician
and the magician has a machine. And as you
step inside this machine, you get to be in
any novel you want. So, he chooses a chapter
of "Madame Bovary", where Emma Bovary is making
love with her lover in a carriage and it's
a very good chapter to be in.
He, of course, is the lover. But then he's
stuck there in the Kugelmass--. Anyway, he
can't get out of this. He's in "Madame Bovary".
And I think that just as you don't wanna be
stuck in the novel, that it was great to be
in that one chapter, but then he's stuck with
Emma Bovary and she starts to just be the
bitch she really is in "Madame Bovary".
[laughter]
He just wanted to be in the carriage with
her, but then there's the next chapter. You
don't wanna be stuck in constant search. I
mean, I think that's the issue. If all you're
doing all day is searchin' and surfin', we
have to learn to live with the novel and we
have to learn to live with the capacity for
search and do other things, too.
And I think that's where we're at now. We're
in this very rapidly learning curve, but we
have to recognize it for what it is. It's
a very rapid learning curve of learning how
to live with this very powerful new device.
It's very exciting, but it also needs us to
be, it needs us to be aware and it needs us
to be not afraid to say we're doing something
very hard.
We're doing something very new, very complicated.
And we can't get jumpy and all nervous if
somebody says, 'Think about it." So that's
what I'm saying. [pause]
>>Female Audience Member #7: Hi.
>>Sherry Turkle: Hi.
>>Female Audience Member #7: Thank you for
your talk and thank you for coming. My question
is how do you see this conversation evolving
because technology is so seductive. And with
your example with food, food is also very
seductive and obesity is a rising problem.
And so, how is it that we can force the conversation
to go in a way that seems unattractive? I
tend to keep my phone off. I don't check my
email very often. I like writing long emails
and having conversations with people and when
I do do that, when my friends--
>>Sherry Turkle: The hostility towards you--
>>Female Audience #7: It is. It's like everyone's
like, "Why couldn't I reach you? Is something
wrong with your phone? [audience laughter]
Is something wrong with you?" And I'm the
one who's an anachronism. So how is it that
we can have this conversation at all when
the alternative just like, letting it evolve
and letting ourselves sink into technology
is so much better?
>>Sherry Turkle: Well, I think we're having
this conversation now. I mean, I'm only one
person and there's only one book. I'm not
saying I wrote the--. But I think that the
time is right. I think we've lived with this
now for--.
We had to live with this first. I think that
we had to have a little experience. I think
you can't like, have Google for 15 minutes
and then say, "Oh my God. I see ten of Facebook
for five years. And then I see a problem."
I mean, I think you have to live with it.
And I think people then have to say, "Well,
I see--." I had a friend who has a 13-year
old daughter.
And here's just an interesting example of
how, I think, people start to see it in ways
that are surprising. And it can't always be
the same old story of, "Oh, my boyfriend put
away his[ ]." This is an interesting example.
So she tells me about a birthday party and
she has a 15-year old daughter. And 15-year
olds, there's a point at a 15-year old party
where there's a lull and then they have to
work through it.
And that's part of the point. They work through
it. But now they're all on their phones and
so they all contact elsewhere. And they all
left because they all had else--. I mean,
they all could bail. And I thought, I forget
if I told you this story. But I mean, there
was something about that story and its particularity.
And you know that sense of always bailing.
I think we're gonna start to see, just in
our everyday lives as we really have experiences,
that we need to just begin to strike a balance.
And I think you're gonna see more and more
people just saying, "We're giving up on something
here." So I think that it's not gonna be,
it's gonna start with small things. It's gonna
start with people not taking calls.
It's gonna start--. First of all, kids are
starting to complain. So just as my generation
rebelled against how their parents treated
them. Then you had a group of parents who
treated their children differently and their
parents. So that generation did the opposite.
The children I am interviewing now, their
parents texted at dinner.
And they work on--. Let me prep these. I'm
not sure the ages of everybody here, but the
children I'm interviewing-- 8, 9, 10, 11,
12, 13, 14, 15-- their parents are texting
at dinner. They are begging their mothers
to make shorter meals so that maybe then their
fathers won't text during dinner. Their fathers
are texting on Sunday watching the games with
them.
Their mothers are having their phones out
while they're reading to them. Their mothers
are pushing the swings with one hand and have
the phone in the other hand. I do fieldwork
in a playground where there's texting and
they're watching the jungle gym, texting.
The kid is going like this on the jungle gym
and the mother can't look up.
These children are not gonna let their children
text, are not gonna text with their kids.
So I mean, you talk about the accommodation
is that there's gonna be an evolution so that
in a few years--. Last night on Steven Colbert,
I was describing this and he said, "Oh, why
don't they just change it?" He says, "Why
don't they just change their Facebook status
to 'abandoned'?"
[laughter]
You're gonna have, you're gonna have those
children not doing it. So I think we're gonna
get--. So, I'm optimistic despite everything
that you read about, the reviews you read
about me, I'm optimistic. I think that we're
gonna get better at this.
And I think we're gonna have these robots
in these nursing homes and we're gonna start
to say, "Couldn't we spend some money on training
some people? These robots – this doesn't
-- this is starting to feel yucky." When you
really watch, I mean, how many people have
had the experience of really watching a woman
who's lost a son, try to, explaining that,
explaining that to a robot that's going, "Uh-huh.
Uh-huh. Uh-huh."
Now, I have had that experience. It totally
creeped me out. But not that many people have
really sat there and, and had that experience.
And I'm telling you, when more of us have
had that experience of people pouring out
their little hearts to robots who you know
understand nothing, I think we can say, I
say send in some college freshmen to this--.
I say really mobilize and have an AmeriCorps
program for this. This is just not, this is
not a happy feeling, here. And I think we're
gonna get more sophisticated about this. So
I say stand your ground. OK.
>>Male Audience Member #8: Yeah, I sort of
hope this is true, although I'm not sure that
I [clears throat] am all that optimistic.
It seems to me that as technologists, we've
effectively realized Joe Weizenbaum's worst
nightmares and we're living through it right
now. And I see this in my own children and
how they interact with their people and also
with younger people here at Google and so
on. And I'm wondering if we've gone past that
point of no return.
>>Sherry Turkle: Well, OK. This is what I--.
When I hear "the horse is out of the barn",
read the book. But when I hear "the horse
is out of the barn", I mean, I taught with
Joe and I got to MIT. I taught courses with
Joe and he felt that the story was over in
1976. And I really believe that whenever we
take the position "the horse is out of the
barn", "it's done", "we're addicted", "the
children are ruined","it’s over", we can't
afford it. We can't afford it.
It's like in politics. I mean, we've had and
we're gonna have some very, very dark days.
And if you take the position it's over, you
can't--. We can't afford it. So I, who've
had some very dark days writing this book,
I mean, as you can tell that I—[pause].
Nanny-bots, they don't ring my bell.
And going to conferences where people are
talking about the--. You travel in, in, in
Japan. Is there a problem with Nanny-bots?
Is there a problem with elder-care bots? And
teacher bots? I mean, these are like, it's
like, does anybody see a problem? Nobody raises
their hand. I mean, there's not even a language
for discussing what the problem might be.
I mean, sometimes you even need to struggle
to find a way to describe what the problem
might be. Because, really, notions about individual
autonomy and privacy, these are not--. Here,
I'm still speaking with a common, shared sense
of what these things might be. So, rave reviews
about sex bots. No problem. I mean, not even
a conversation about why that might be a problem.
So, I'm not saying that I don't share some
of your trepidation. But I'm absolutely convinced
that we have not begun to have the conversation
we need to have, when still, a book like this,
which is not an angry book. It's a, "Hey,
let’s talk" book is reviewed, "She doesn't
like technology. She doesn't like technology,
I don't like her."
And we can do better as a conversation. I
mean, not that some people haven't liked the
book, but for people to respond that way means
that we have to work harder to have that conversation.
[pause] Thank you very much. It's really been
a pleasure.
[applause]